[Musica]
avete mai pensato che i libri della
vostra biblioteca non sono silenziosi
anzi hanno una voce molte voci
ogni libro infatti ha una sua voce la
voce dell'autore che la scritta e anche
la voce del lettore che ridà vita a ciò
che ha scritto l'autore e quindi ogni
libro ha una sua voce e quando noi
abbiamo il libro e cominciamo a leggerlo
ci ritroviamo dentro un concerto di voci
che ci coinvolgono e ci portano nel
passato oppure ci proiettano anche anche
nel futuro
ecco appunto ogni libro ha una sua voce
e questa voce va però cercata anche da
noi e vari creata in noi quindi non solo
gli scrittori sono creativi anche i
lettori sono creativi e quando appunto
leggiamo noi immaginiamo le parole che
stiamo leggendo che ci legano quindi
emotivamente e ci coinvolgono
emotivamente quindi si creano si creano
dei legami tra noi e le parole tra noi e
gli altri tra noi gli scrittori è un
legame quindi un legame emotivo che ci
coinvolge e che ci lega agli altri è un
modo anche per ascoltare gli altri
quindi ogni libro ha una sua voce noi
dobbiamo metterci in ascolto di questa
di questa voce che ci racconta che ci ha
raccontato una volta una storia una
poesia un racconto una fiaba
ogni libro ha una sua voce noi ci
leghiamo ed ereditiamo
questa voce il nostro modo anche di
essere figli attraverso la parola il
nostro modo di ereditare le parole degli
altri quindi anche le parole dei nostri
antenati si dice infatti che un classico
è sempre vivo perché appunto perché noi
ereditiamo la voce dei nostri classici
anche se non ne siamo consapevoli non ne
siamo veramente consapevoli
abbiamo una nostra memoria estesa una
nostra immaginazione una voce appunto
dell'immaginazione la voce creativa che
ricrea in noi quei mondi di fantasia e
che noi riempiamo anche della nostra
esperienza e questo il fatto
fondamentale cioè noi riempiamo della
nostra esperienza mondi di fantasia di
altri e quindi questo legame
ogni classico quindi è un
è un testo di un segno di vita a cui noi
dobbiamo ridare vita quindi non solo gli
scrittori sono creativi lo sono anche i
lettori ognuno di noi ha una sua memoria
estesa un suo nutrimento nutrimento al
quale attingere sempre appunto per
immaginare mondi e visioni situazioni
anche per immaginare anche il nostro
futuro è un nutrimento lo nutrimento che
ci lega agli altri e quindi che noi
utilizziamo anche per pensare a noi
stessi alla nostra vita ognuno di noi ha
una sua biblioteca che gli bisbiglia
qualcosa
ecco facciamo qualche esempio di questa
biblioteca che bisbiglia già
sant'agostino e petrarca sostenevano che
la lettura la scrittura non un modo
ovviamente importantissimo per
riflettere quindi per compiere
riflessioni interiori ma anche per
rigenerarsi e cosa vuol dire rigenerarsi
appunto ricreare questi legami questi
legami appunto queste voci e noi ricci
ricreiamo attraverso le voci dei nostri
antenati
qualche esempio appunto
io faccio i miei che sono quelli popoli
della mia della mia professione della
mia del mio studio come non volere bene
a dante per esempio quando scrive noi
leggiamo per l'ennesima volta leggo per
l'ennesima volta nel mezzo del cammin di
nostra vita io mi sento andare con lui
come non provare rispetto per petrarca
francesco petrarca quando ci chiede di
metterci in sintonia con le sue angosce
con le sue i suoi drammi appunto amorosi
ma anche della coscienza della sua
interiorità e appunto scrive voi che
ascoltate in rime sparse il suono poi ci
chiede di ascoltare e come non amare
boccaccio quando all'inizio del
decameron scrive la prima cosa che
scrive scrive umana cose aver con
passione degli afflitti umana cosa
quindi io mi sento legata mi sento di
appartenere in quel momento mentre leggo
sono coinvolta e faccio rivivere in me
le voci dei miei antenati che io scelgo
che io scelgo personalmente di avere
intorno a me ma gli esempi possono
essere tanti vi possono coinvolgere no
ogni libro una sua voce e per esempio
gelosie
innamorati ci parlano in continuazione
nella letteratura juliette desdemona per
esempio sono eroine del nostro tempo chi
ha amato l'uomo sbagliato contro il
volere del padre
ecco che juliet e desdemona sono delle
rovine che ci raccontano questo tema
questo problema ci coinvolgono chi è mai
stato geloso
siamo stati gelosi ecco che l otello e
desdemona sono il riflesso delle nostre
paure juliet e desdemona per esempio che
sono state rese terme dal genio di
shakespeare forse ci dobbiamo ricordare
che sono state inventate dai narratori
italiani dai narratori del nostro
rinascimento
ecco questa è la mia biblioteca che mise
bisbiglia quando io vivo quando io cerco
di immaginare il mio futuro
quindi non solo gli scrittori sono
creativi ma lo siamo anche noi lettori
cioè il classico e vivo per questo
perché ha bisogno di noi per essere per
rivivere per essere per parlare ancora
quindi per riuscire ad attivare noi quei
mondi che noi attiviamo a nostra volta
il classico quindi hai bisogno di noi e
noi abbiamo bisogno di lui per capire
anche lo spettacolo delle relazioni
umane per immaginare appunto il nostro
futuro
ma c'è un ostacolo leggere
leggere e faticose faticoso per tutti e
faticoso anche per me ovviamente è
perché è faticoso perché l'incontro tra
il lettore e il libro è un incontro che
non può anche non essere felice a volte
può essere proprio vero fallimento come
può essere anche un fallimento
incontrare una persona che non si vede
da molto tempo oppure che non si conosce
bene all'inizio 6 diffidenti se ostili
disorientati e se anche se anche
distratti
ecco distratti noi lo siamo di sicuro
perché noi siamo lo sappiamo bene siamo
immersi in un mondo che ci coinvolge ci
travolge siamo in un universo diciamo
così culturale e fluttuante aperto noi
non riusciamo a sempre a cogliere queste
voci dei libri a volte le intercettiamo
queste voci dei libri a volte no
a volte non le sentiamo oppure ci
annoiano c stufano ci se ne sentiamo
lontane perché appunto siamo distratti
siamo disorientati a volte siamo anche
francamente ostili non abbiamo voglia di
ricreare quindi questo legame che un
legame assolutamente di eredità
ed è anche un legame diciamo così
sentimentale italo calvino ama il suo
lettore e ama i suoi lettori in un
bellissimo libro che conoscerete
sicuramente sono notti d'inverno un
viaggiatore si immagina di parlare
direttamente al suo lettore e capisce la
fatica del lettore che è stata anche la
sua fatica dice che anche ha fatto
fatica e fa fatica faceva fatica a
scrivere la scrittura la comunque un
processo diciamo così aerobico quasi
come una ginnastica continuamente
riscriveva e così anche la lettura
perché non ammetterlo anche la lettura e
faticosa però la vedeva anche come un
incapacità del
dell'umanità di fermarsi e di mettersi
in ascolto con l'altro ecco perché
continuava a chiamare dentro il lettore
dentro al suo libro e scrive appunto
direttamente parlando direttamente
lettore scrive magari tu lettore tu
in principio provi un po di
disorientamento ma poi prosegue ti
accorgi che il libro si fa leggere
comunque anzi a pensarci bene preferisci
che sia così trovarti di fronte a
qualcosa che ancora non sai bene cos'è
ecco qui c'è un regalo di italo calvino
che che ci da noi è vero ci capisce
siamo disorientati però tutti accorgi
che ha certo punto prosegue e ti accorgi
che il libro si fa leggere comunque il
regalo qual è il regalo il futuro pc beh
a pensarci bene
preferisci che sia così perché per
calvino la lettura è un'avventura
misteriosa che vale comunque la pena di
fare
non sappiamo come il libro si comporterà
con noi dove ci porterà che cosa ci dirà
però ci chiede di ascoltarlo ci chiede
di partire con lui
ecco perché
le nostre biblioteche non sono
silenziose ma anzi sono questo
bisbigliare di voci allegre tristi somma
sempre vitali che sta a noi metterci in
ascolto metterci in ascolto e partire
per un'avventura questa avventura
preferisce che se è così che sia
un'avventura quindi leggere per
immaginare per immaginare cosa per
essere più mani per essere legati e
anche per immaginare qualcosa che non
sappiamo ancora bene cosa sarà
[Applauso]
a
[Musica]